foreign
[Music]
what is up from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions broadcasting from the
PODS moving and storage Studio this is
the Ramsay show where America hangs out
to have a conversation about your money
your life your work your relationships
anything and everything triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined here by George
Campbell my good buddy we are taking
your calls on everything life money
relationships whatever you got going on
in your life give us a call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five mental
health issues relationship stuff work
stuff your money questions all of it
we're here for you let's go out to
Samantha in Baltimore Maryland hey
Samantha what's happening Hi how are you
guys today we're good how are you
I'm doing okay a little nervous hey we
are too but hey we've never lost anybody
yet so let's give it a go
um so my question is is um how do I get
gazelle intense when I had to recently
quit my second job because of health
issues I'm having what are your health
issues
um so I was hospitalized three times
this year
um and the last time was for mental
health and it was just the stress of
going to school full-time working a
full-time job in a part-time job was
just too much and I couldn't my body
couldn't handle it anymore hey can I
just tell you I'm proud of you
for telling somebody you needed some
help
that was hard yeah it's real hard and
you're a brave strong strong woman I'm
proud of you
thank you I in a similar situation did
not tell people I needed help and I
crashed and I almost took my family with
me so I'm proud of you way to go thank
you
um you are going gazelle intense you're
going as fast as your car can go
be okay with that okay okay and it might
take you a little bit longer than you
had on your spreadsheet or in your color
chart or whatever you had but you're
going hard hard and you're doing two
things at once you're getting yourself
out of debt with your full-time job and
eating and surviving and you're
investing in yourself in the future with
your education so you're doing great
how much longer do you have on your
journey
semester and I realized that that was a
bad mistake
about the student loan and then I found
you guys cool okay hey so can we do one
thing
sure
um when we get off the phone I want you
to do this okay I want you to go outside
and find a rock or a brick or something
laying around outside and I want you to
write
student loan on it okay I don't want you
to carry it around for five or ten
minutes 15 20 minutes until it gets
really heavy and annoying and it starts
hurting your fingers a little bit I
don't want you to take it out in your
backyard and throw it down on the ground
and I want you to I want you to think
about anymore
okay you're I don't want you beating
yourself up over something you did
before you found us it happened I took
out six figures of student loans George
had a student loan like we all have them
okay we've all been there we've all made
dumb mistakes and then the question is
not
um how hard can I beat myself up because
I made stupid mistakes but the question
is what am I going to do now and you're
on the right path
thank you so much how much longer do you
have till you are out of debt about two
years awesome
um is there another job you can do
that's not going to drive your mental
and physical health into the ground
um I don't know that's what it was I've
been trying to figure out
um I recently got a raise on my first
job so I was able to relieve some of the
stress I was having from the second job
very cool uh what is your what is your
job
I'm an office manager for a foreign
company
oh very cool
you all haven't been busy the last few
years huh no it was very slow what were
you doing for your uh off job I mean
your your side hustle I was a cashier at
a Giant food store oh geez
I don't make most of us have mental
health issues if that's our only job
right yes have you thought about a job
like driving Uber or something where you
can listen to your own music and your
own podcast and really be on your own or
doing doordash or something like that
where you're kind of in your own Planet
but you're also making some money on the
side
no I haven't bought a doordash okay Uber
Uber scares me a little bit that's fair
yeah if you don't want other people in
your car there's things like doordash
and instacart where I do instacart John
I don't drive for it but I have people
come drop the groceries off I never see
them I'm very thankful for them I tip
them nicely but there's no interaction
with with humans other than going to the
store and making the purchases so that
could be a great option for you as well
that you can do on your own time when
you're in the mood when you're in a good
spot you just turn that on for an hour
or two and pick up some uh some uh gigs
like that and the cool thing about that
one is if you wake up and you're running
pretty low you're having a hard day
right and you know what I'm talking
about when I say that right
yeah um you don't have to go
you just flip the switch and you don't
turn your app on and they don't call you
and on the days you wake up and the
light is really bright outside and you
feel great like you can take on the
world you can go pick up some shifts and
drive for three or four hours if you got
the time and you can drive on the way to
work you can drive on the way home from
work
um I the last person that drove me an
Uber
um was driving just to work from in here
in Nashville and drop me off at the
airport and I was like I was like you
driving he goes no I'm I'm like an
engineer or something he had some fancy
job he's like I just thought I would
take your 60 bucks on my way to work and
I thought what a great gig right so
there's there's ways around it I I think
taking a break is a good idea but I also
think what is another thing I could do
where I could keep myself healthy and
earn some bucks on the side and take
that two years down to 18 months right
yes that's unfair trying to I'm trying
to sign my car to help get out of debt
and I just haven't found a buyer willing
to pay what I need for it to pay it off
that's cool just keep keep grinding it
and keep working at it yeah and you can
not only check out you know posted on
Facebook Marketplace or auto trader but
some of these online companies are
paying top dollar for cars so I would
really do some homework and research
there and see if you can put it on room
or carvana and they go we'll give you
what you owe on it today just just yeah
we need cars right we need inventory is
low
um George how many people you you sit
with folks who are starting their their
baby steps Journey or they're in the
middle of it and the idea you know you
see Dave on the videos running across
the stage doing his like Arsenio Hall
our move like you see it happening yeah
yeah and the idea of gazelle intensity
sounds so great oh yeah and then you get
away from the conference or the video is
over and you get into your life and
you're like ah it's not great I have to
cut my lifestyle down to zero and not
eat out and get three more jobs okay
yeah how many people do you talk to
struggle there right it's like all right
we're going all in it's like oh all ends
everything yeah all it's hard and
everyone has their version of hard for
some people not eating out for a year is
like they can't even imagine you that is
very difficult having to go to the
grocery store on your own meal prep oh I
was like that's only for crossfitters
only crossfitters do that and people who
are intentional with their money yes and
so that is a hard thing eating out is
one of the biggest things cutting
lifestyle and subscriptions because I
was used to just kind of being selfish
and going I just want to spend 150 bucks
on me this month and I got the mani pedi
and I went to the movies and I went to
the mall and all of a sudden you go I
gotta be intentional and if I don't need
to spend it I'm not gonna spend it
because I have priorities and that's a
hard shift to make mentally to put laser
energy Focus onto one thing at one time
because we're so scattered yeah and
let's let's address what I think is
become an elf in the room for many
people and I'm so glad that Samantha
brought that up
if your health is not okay pause paying
off your debt right and get well you are
more important than your debt yes if you
were if you are not if you're tired
because you're going to be tired you're
going to be exhausted if you find
yourself clinically depressed or
clinically anxious you need to go talk
to somebody stop
stop these jobs take a break for a
second all right
um there's no good in out running the
lion if when you're out by the time you
outrun the lion you don't make it right
um so we got to be well on this journey
I'm so proud of Samantha and so many
others for saying to a counselor to a
professional I need some help because
I'm not okay if it takes you longer
because of that I'm okay with it you
don't get a gold medal because you got
burnt out exactly you just get burnt out
do it on your own time triple eight
eight two five five two two five this is
the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
hey what's up it's triple eight eight
two five five two two five this is the
Ramsey Show I'm John deloney joined here
by George Campbell and we're taking your
calls on your money and your
relationships and your life let's go out
to Aaliyah in Sioux City Iowa what's up
Alia how we doing
hello
um I just wanted to say thank you for
all that you guys are doing my husband
and I when we first started dating we
went through Financial Peace University
and it really set up a foundation and
then we were empty ish for a while and
then now we're back on track and we're
on baby step two and I just we need some
guidance on what to do where
we've been married for about six months
and I know like everybody's timeline is
different but we're ready to have kids
but also like we're not like stressing
about it but we're in this place of like
it's gonna take about a year to pay off
debt and I'd like to stay home
um we both would really like for me to
stay home but then on top of that we're
like struggling we're you know nine
months to be pregnant but then like
um to be intense gazelle intense we're
trying to figure out that balance
because you say don't pause your life
for the baby steps but also it almost
seems like we have to it'd be just
overthinking it but on top of that my
husband
um he's been studying apologetics for
about 12 years and
um I just I almost John this is for you
I almost feel a little guilty because if
I stay home then
he really wants to do something with
like in Ministry and we haven't really
figured out what yet and we're just
dipping our feet into the water and
taking all that time but I don't know
like we haven't really figured out like
a solid like I don't know footing of
what's our plan and how we're gonna do
it and I just I I just if you guys could
give us some insight on all of that
that'd be wonderful yes okay so first
thing Aaliyah I want you to take a deep
as as deep a breath as you can and hold
it okay I want you to hold it for a
count of three three okay take a big
deep breath three
two one and when you let it out I want
you to intentionally pull your elbows
down and pull your shoulders away from
your ears I can hear them creeping up
okay
and how old are you
I'm 22 my husband's 29. okay and you
said you've been married how long
okay
100 it's gonna be all right
okay
um you are dress rehearsing tragedy
you're trying to think of every bad
thing that might happen someday and
solving for it in the present
and the only expense you're paying for
this is the present
so you're cashing in your joy today your
laughter today your intimacy today your
new marriage all running around making
out whenever you want to you're catching
all that in for yeah but in five years
or in three years you know what could
happen okay yeah and there's wisdom in
putting 15 in your retirement when
you're ready there's wisdom in paying
your house off there's wisdom in being
out of debt all those things are wise
and good that's planning ahead but
that's not pathologically stealing from
today to pretend to mortgage for a
future see what I'm saying
yes and so it's so good to have an idea
when you're going to get pregnant I've
had friends they're like man we want to
think about having kids in 36 months and
they're pregnant within 48 hours
me and my wife it took like four years
right and so yeah and that's the thing
is I have um I have a friend that I'm
close to
um I guess it's a big fear of mine it's
fertility she lost um she lost a couple
before they had children so so let me I
want to tell you this at 22. okay
100 chance you will experience loss and
tragedy and hurt over your lifetime
okay you already have that's right and
probably you have and you're highly
highly attuned to letting it ever happen
again and that's a Fool's errand okay it
will happen again so instead of trying
to prohibit everything that comes
that's why we say pay off your house and
don't owe anybody any money because when
it comes then it's annoying it's not
life-ending that's why I tell you that
other people are your emergency fund for
life not if but when your husband gets
sick someday you'll have three friends
that can show up with some old tacos and
half a bottle of wine to your house and
keep you company while you go visit him
see what I'm saying
it's not if but when okay so we're the
whole Ramsay plan the Ramsey way of
doing things is setting up your life so
that when things come
you are equipped to handle them not
prohibiting them from coming ever
because they're going to come the second
thing is is you are now entering into
um rather quickly
actually you're you're choosing to join
it at this point but it is the modern
hell that is being a woman a part of a
guilt complex industrial guilt complex
okay very aware of it sir if you stay at
home I should be working and
contributing and if I work I should be
staying at home and there's blogs and
products and things all designed for one
purpose to make you feel less than to
make you feel like you're robbing your
husband or your family or your church or
your kids
so you'll go buy stuff to fix it
okay yeah and so I'm just trying to find
what what fits us and I want to honor my
husband
meet our family and I want to I want to
be the best wife that I can be and I've
just had a lot of criticism where um I
haven't technically finished my
four-year degree and there's a lot of
people that are like you're wasting so
much of your potential Hey listen listen
I want you to I want you to internalize
the saying if they don't get a vote
yes I've heard you say that yes you have
given one person permission to have a
vote and that's your husband and you may
have one or two or three close close
writer die friends that have a vote too
your parents may not have a boat anymore
your in-laws for sure don't have a vote
your old College roommates that y'all
used to be friends and now you're kind
of like I don't they don't get a vote
that guy at church that's like you
should be a doctor what are you doing he
didn't get a vote they don't get a vote
right they don't get a vote they don't
get a vote they don't get a vote
you're a lot nice for the me John I just
say thank you for your opinion but we
are not taking a poll at this time
please try again later but it's so true
there's a such a guilt around this whole
situation and we always tell people you
can have a baby while in baby step two
yes it's possible and when you get
pregnant you pause the debt snowball we
save up a bunch of cash and maybe we
have five six seven nine thousand
dollars and mom and baby are home safe
now we use that money to throw it to
death yes it's that simple and so your
life is not going to be upended by this
the baby becomes a budget line item that
we're gonna add and you go oh we're
alive right it's really hard and we're
really tired all the time but life is
not that much different now we'd like to
have more margin and he may need to get
a side job while he's doing apologetics
because we need to put food on the table
and that's part of the compromise and
sacrifice we make to have the things
that we want right and and Aaliyah you
may have a picture of in your mind of
staying at home
and it may be when the baby turns two
and a half
you all have created enough financial
margin that that's possible for you in
conjunction with your husband's job and
his ministry and whatever else he's got
going all right so we get really static
George we get fixed on it's got to be
right this way right now forever man did
play by play six six months to a year to
six months after that and let's let's do
this thing in seasons and Aaliyah if I'm
you I'd be working two or three jobs
right now you're 22. I would be out
there getting after it your husband
should be working two jobs and going to
school y'all should be socking away as
much cash as humanly possible so that if
or when you get pregnant you'll have
options to make choices right George
that's the thing this that magic word
margin that the Ramsey playing we talk
about peace we talk about peace talk
about peace I think we've reached a
point where people don't know what peace
looks like and feels like anymore all of
our parents are angry all of our
neighbors are angry all of our churches
are yelling at everybody I don't think
we know what peace is anymore right and
well we're looking everywhere else to
figure out what that looks like everyone
else has to give it to me right like you
you can't disagree with me you got to
give me peace you can't fire me you got
to give me peace you can't make me
disturb my peace at my job you've got to
give me p no man peace comes from the
inside out right yeah and so many people
in borrowed future the documentary we
hear stories about couples going I don't
feel like I can start a family I feel
like I'm a failure as a husband because
of my debt Shame Shame debt has so much
guilt and shame attached to it and
there's logistical pieces where you go
you're right you can't afford to be a
homeowner that's why you're in debt and
that's a part of the reality that we're
facing here uh you know just crippled by
debt that's exactly so it's a great
Noble goal to say I want to get out of
debt and have an emergency fund by the
time where we have a baby and if we
don't that's okay too it's all right and
I want to I want to I don't know I want
to live here in this house and this side
it may not happen just yet it may happen
in 10 years from now and that's okay
it's just a knockout just a nut now
we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five every
time you hear somebody do their debt
free scream on the show it's because at
some point they said I've had it I'm not
living like this anymore when you get
mad like that and do what they did your
life will change too and right now
inflation and your stupid credit cards
are killing you you've been led to
believe that you're not in control of
your money that's wrong
you have to decide to control what you
can control and that's you your thoughts
your actions you have the power to
change your future and Financial Peace
University will show you how this course
will teach you the proven step-by-step
plan that's helped nearly 10 million
people beat debt Master budgeting and
build wealth and you can do it too stop
letting debt and money stress control
your life say I've had it and take back
your control start Financial Peace
University at ramseysolutions.com FPU
that's ramsesolutions.com
FPU all right let's go to Jake in
Portland what's up brother Jake
hey how's it going guys it's good what's
on my call you got it oh I just the
first I wanted to say George uh you're a
man's man and I would have you at my
poker table any day of the week I've
been wanting to hear those words Hey
listen live Jake I have to let you know
something important those words have
never been uttered in the English
language before congratulations you've
said an original sentence Oh man in
there Jake's like Shakespeare thank you
I don't know if this is a prank call or
someone paid you but I appreciate you my
brother so what's up man all right well
well here's here's the thing so um I I
need some guidance on a financial path
so in uh March of 2020 I got divorced
and it was at a time where I was
transitioning careers uh from like sales
into nursing which is a big paradigm
shift but it happened when I was still
in school I had no job I had a
three-year-old son and I was really
stressful and I felt like my I lost
everything I lost my home I lost my
marriage my son lost his family it was
it was awful and so I like just landed
like crazy because I told myself I was
going to give him all those things again
and so I've just been laser focused on
saving money for a house
um to give him that home and during this
time I I happened to meet somebody else
and I've fallen in love and so my plan
for buying this house has kind of
changed because I've heard you guys talk
about how if you buy a house while
you're dating somebody your things are
going to get shuffled up because it
doesn't like I just started renting the
spot not too long ago and sure enough
she came in she hated the cupboard she
hates everything about it so she
definitely doesn't want to leave yeah
so we're gonna be
my plan is to still buy a house but I
want to do it with her after we get
married which I don't know when that's
going to be and she's also going to
nursing school because I got this has
kind of been pushed out I've I make
about 180 000 a year
um over the past couple years I've saved
about 150 000 for a down payment houses
run anywhere from five to seven hundred
right now in my area
um and so since that's been put on pause
and I'm I'm kind of transitioning out of
my intense phase to more of an
intentional phase
um I've been thinking about maybe buying
a new car I drive a 2011 Honda Civic
it's got like 160 000 miles and the auto
Civic Hybrid which I know you like
George Ross is so big it's so big that I
can't fit like my son's bike or a
suitcase in the trunk and so it's like
it crushes him always in the back so I
thought about getting a new car and I've
been thinking about maybe buying a truck
for and um I mean if you can't buy any
new ones right now but I was thinking
about buying the trunk about about fifty
thousand dollars since I'm looking at
being years out from buying this house
while her and I kind of figure out what
our next steps are going to be and so I
just don't know I have a hard time
spending that money when I've been my
one goal has been this house
and now I don't know what to do so you
think it'd be stupid to buy this car or
I don't think anything here is is a
stupid or unwise I was just thinking
wouldn't it be cheaper to buy a bike to
have at your place than to buy a new car
to transport a bike
I I mean he has a bike like if we go for
a bike ride at the park or something
um and I do a lot of mountain biking so
I go up to the trails you can mount it
on top with a rack
um they're not typically designed for
children's bikes but I don't know much
about that but I'm just thinking there
may be us anytime it's like I gotta buy
a new car for a bike oh my God
like you can get a new car I want you to
upgrade in car but not because of it
can't fit a suitcase I want you to do it
because it's time to upgrade and you've
got the you've done really well I mean
you make great income you've done the
hard work and you're going a million
miles an hour it feels like have you
taken the time just to grieve everything
you've lost the last few years
yeah I mean I I think I have lots of
people around me because I've been
putting a lot of time
um with work and they say I should do
something for myself because I don't do
anything all I do is save money and so
people are encouraging me because I've
been talking about buying a truck for
like decades and crazy I think I'm old
enough to say that and so like you
should just buy the truck because you
like you need it and I'm like well
you're not trying to buy this house I'm
like well what if you don't live long
enough to get the house
that's stupid that's that's why
America's America right now YOLO get the
truck now Hey Jake why uh in one
sentence why did you get divorced
oh Jesus
um we
we grew apart we were like cohabitating
and we didn't invest enough in us and we
just it was a slow drift I remember
sitting there on bed and I'd be on my
phone and she'd be on her phone yep and
thinking to myself this isn't right who
filed on who
um she filed on me did she meet somebody
uh no okay
you have all of the actions and the the
language of somebody who still is
wondering what's wrong with me
you need to buy a house for you not your
kid
because your kid is going to be
successful when Dad is whole
your kid is not going to suddenly have a
magical childhood because he's got four
walls and a roof that looks like we came
out of Dad's imagination
yeah he's gonna be okay when dad's okay
and you can't give him something you
don't have
and so
like George asked like
you gotta stop and feel this and I don't
think you have I think you got divorced
and immediately started sprinting for
your life
and that's cool and you survived and now
you are making a ton of money and you
are continuing to try to seek peace
externally
yeah and that that finish line just
keeps moving and moving and moving and
moving
and that piece is going to have to come
from the inside out
I mean truthfully yeah I I feel like I
would get this truck and then I would
still feel 100 like I don't know I need
something else this truck will be nice
and Jordan I mean it falls in the
parameters you're fine it's less than
half of what you make you can pay cash
for it all those things it checks all
the boxes
just know that buying this truck is not
going to give you peace it's not going
to make your son and suddenly go ah
now dad's got it to get that's not going
to happen
it's not it's the same Jake that's gonna
be driving that truck will show up that
next day yes and so I want you to do
these things like John's saying for you
and it sounds like everything so far has
been like well my friends have been
nagging me about the truck and I got to
get the house for her and she's may not
even like it when you do it on your
terms it's different and so you might be
a few years out the numbers you shared I
mean you make a great income is your
take-home pay about 10 grand
uh yeah okay so you might need to save
up 300 Grand and put that down on a 550
000 house to have the payments make
sense and that might mean it's three
years out and we might mean you get
married and you still are renting for a
while and she still hates the cabinets
and she still goes uh you can make so
much money why are you driving this old
Civic and you smile and go because I can
because it's fine because I have no one
to impress I've got value and I've got
worth and it's not found in a
depreciating asset and if you want to go
buy it a twenty thousand dollar truck go
for it
I mean just know it's not going to solve
your problems
it might help you get the bike to the
park and it might set you back on the
home purchase and we go okay it's gonna
send me back you know three five six
months on the home purchase and I'm okay
with that I'm running my own race
here's the deal Jake at some point you
have to start Outsourcing what you want
and what you need and what you feel to
other people you've got a new girlfriend
and you've already outsourced
what you think you can live in what you
want to live into somebody else
already outsourced your future too I've
got to do all these things for my son
otherwise he's gonna you're out about to
buy a 50 000 truck so you can get your
bike from your house to the neighborhood
park
your friends are telling ask yourself
this question what do I want what do I
actually need
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsey Show I'm John
deloney joined here by my good friend
George camel let's go out to Alexis in
Phoenix hey Alexis what's happening
okay absolutely what's up
all right so
tell me this morning that my parents
have had to dip into their savings this
past two months okay
um she's my mom has stayed home with us
and homeschooled us for 10 years
um and she's gonna have to get a
part-time job
um and I'm just wondering like how my
savings and how me saving for my future
it's into that because I kind of feel
guilty
having extra money every month or having
my own money putting into savings while
they're struggling yeah
man they are lucky they're they're lucky
to have you as their kid you are the
oldest 15 year old I've ever taught now
it's fantastic okay I'm gonna tell you
something really hard to internalize and
you're gonna hear these words and your
your guts aren't gonna believe me okay
it's not your job
you are doing an incredible job planning
for your future and your parents have
made grown-up choices like whatever job
your Dad is working at is a choice he's
chosen to work and that's his trade
that's what he does
um and your mom made a choice we want to
stay at home that was a collective
values-based decision that they made and
then there's a math problem they ran
into and like adults all over the
country Brave adults are saying okay
this is what we wanted this isn't going
to be this isn't the way this is going
to work out for a while so we're gonna
have to alter our plan and do something
else
and so I'm actually proud of your
parents for doing that that's awesome
it's just going to look different
okay yeah the greatest thing you can do
for your parents is you take care of
your business in the classroom you take
care of your business like as a teammate
around that house right make sure you
take care of your responsibilities with
Excellence which I know you do and be
sober minded be intentional about
planning for the future what college is
going to look like what it's going to
cost where are you going to go what are
you going to study all of those things
that's the way you support your parents
not by taking your part-time job money
and trying to keep the lights on now
they're making a moment when they ask
you for that it doesn't sound like
that's what's happening it sounds like
your mom set set you down like a good
mom she actually sounds incredible sat
you down and said hey we've had some
hard realities that we're dealing with
and so I'm gonna have to go to work and
so homes gonna look a little different
for a season is that what happened
yeah I I applaud her because a lot of
parents would try to hide that they'd be
ashamed of that they'd be scared of that
and your mom did the right thing she sat
down and told you a hard truth and that
also means that she trusts you
does that make sense that she thinks
you're wise enough to hear that that
scary that scary stuff okay
but keep that in your mind and in your
heart it's not your job okay yeah
do you believe me
yes no you don't but it's okay it's it's
okay if you don't so there are some
tactical things you can do Alexis one is
you know you're 15 you're starting to
enter that age where you can go get some
part-time jobs and one thing you can do
is instead of going hey Mom and Dad I
want the new iPhone it's twelve hundred
dollars
you can go work for that and save for
that and you cover your own expenses of
things that are kind of the luxuries in
your life you don't have to go pay the
water bill but you can cover you know
going out to the movies with your
friends it sounds like you already do
that yeah oh yeah awesome I wasn't sure
if that was okay for me to continue to
have like absolutely I think that's
great yes flexing that muscle at 50. I
wish John and I were that smart at 15.
yes goodness great I didn't know what
day it was when I was 15. and yes you
listen
we often think that pain is some zero or
that grief is some zero and what that
means is that George loses his job
and I get a flat tire
and I am upset I'm lying about my flat
tire and George goes oh yeah you think
that's bad I lost my listen
grief and sadness aren't some zero
you can go have joy while your parents
are making life adjustments at their
home because one doesn't you not you
just sitting at home and not having fun
and not hanging out with your friends
and spending your spending money by
going to the movies you doing that
doesn't help the
the bills get paid you see what I'm
saying
it's just you joining into their misery
into something that you didn't cause
it's not your job okay yeah and so yeah
go have fun with your friends
I love what George says
um if you know hey now's not the time to
go ask for the iPhone whatever 13 or 17
or whatever number they're up to now
that's cool that's fine
um
but do go have joy in your life okay I'm
gonna do one one better for you Alexis
I'm gonna gift you Financial Peace
University and one thing you can do is
you're casually hanging out living room
watching Financial Peace University and
you go hey Mom Dad if you want to join
me like I'm learning so much in this if
you guys want to join me I think it'd be
really cool for us to go through it
together and not as a plate from a place
of Shame of like hey Mom when you're
just tell me you guys are broke this
might be good for you I call them 15
idiots on the radio I got you solved
telling the person who wiped your butt
you know seven years ago this so uh just
go watch it yourself and I think you
modeling that might Inspire them
motivate them give them some hope and
when the time comes you're gonna get
older and they're going to be asking you
for advice that's right and so it's a
great place to be so hang on the line
Jenna's gonna pick up we're gonna gift
you Financial Peace University for one
year as well as every dollar premium and
you can get on a budget at 15 and they
might see you doing that go what was
that you did that's pretty cool go ahead
and send her Anthony O'Neill's
um debt-free degree too Jenna um and she
can start greeting on now and caboodle
college is going to look look like in
the future all right let's go to Vanessa
in Charleston hey Vanessa what's going
on
can you hear me yes ma'am what's up
okay I'm so grateful to talk to you
thank you I'm struggling with some
issues all right bring it on we are too
okay
I'm getting a relationship
um kind of my issue is
um when we met I sold the house that I'd
raised my kids in
um and I had winter Dave Ramsey and I
had cleared all my dents so when we met
I was debt free and I had a little bit
of money in the bank
um
about four years ago we bought a house
close to my daughter and
um
it was real small and another house came
up around the corner and it was in
foreclosure I got a decent deal on it so
I bought it
um I own another house about 20 minutes
away
and part of my issues are number one I
wanted to end the relationship
with my boyfriend
um my other issue is I'm having some
domestic issues with my daughter if you
will and I think maybe some space
Sometimes some part you know some is
Faith between us would be good
um so I have a total of four houses
what's your mortgage total on those four
houses
I'm I'm broke when I leave the
relationship I'll have nothing other
than these houses and my income is his
name on these on the Deeds
no not on me so you your name only is on
all these Deeds
that's right okay so can you sell all
four houses
yeah
I think it's time to start fresh yeah
so my issue with it is well I mean you
know my daughter's having some issues
um you know um is having for is having
being broke and having all of your money
tied up in these four houses gonna help
your daughter
no no
I guess where I'm struggling with it is
you know I mean two of the houses are
rented out do I sell the rentals and try
to save the house that I'm in which is
not necessarily desirable to me it's a
nicest of the houses but it's
um nice to me because I'm close to my
grandkids but my daughter and I are
having some issues
um trying to decide whether or not to
put space between us or what you know
what I mean or do I one of the leases up
for the renters
um
the first of the year okay so when we
say we're not renewing the lease I'm
selling the properties
here's what here's what I want here
here's what I want you to do start
thinking it this way you're trying to
look at this as a math problem it's a
mothering problem as a mental health
issue problem as a relationship problem
whenever my life gets this chaotic I'm
going to clean up my environment and
take as many variables off the table as
possible
and right now you are leveraged to the
gills in four houses that you can't
afford and it doesn't sound like you
even want them
and if I'm you again I would talk to an
attorney before you start dividing all
this up because he may be claims to this
and that I'm going to take the variables
that I can control off the table I can't
control the relationship Mass I can't
control my daughter's situation we're
gonna have to work through that I can
control how chaotic my life is trying to
run four households at the same time I'm
gonna sell the houses and clear that
debt George what do you think agreed
awesome all right hey that's first hour
of the Ramsey Show in the books thank
you for listening we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
co-host of the Ramsey show did you know
over 18
[Music]
Mill people listen on one of our 600
plus radio stations across the country
to find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell Join This Hour by my good
friend Dr John baloney and we are taking
your calls America about money life
mental health boundaries relationships
paying off debt whatever you want to
talk about we are here for you the
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five Sally's kicking us off
in Manhattan Sally welcome to the Ramsay
show how's it going
uh not going great George but thanks for
taking my call I'm sorry to hear that
yeah I gotta just put the honest deck of
cards on the table I just love you all
and I love Dave and anyway here are the
facts I'll I'll be like short and brief
and just interrupting I'm gonna be 58 in
January I've been paying a mortgage on a
small one bedroom since 2004.
right before the pandemic which I won't
even give my opinion about that episode
in our lives
um Chase Bank to whom I was paying a
mortgage every month since 2004 up until
2019 perfectly full I'm very financially
conservative I was raised by financially
conservative people I never missed a
payment on a credit card this kind of
stuff
my mom who was suffering from a terrible
stage of dementia and was dying quickly
basically I and I was in between jobs I
am a professional who works on
assignments
um long hours from months at a time then
there's arrest but then on the sign
somewhere else
and between all of that going on and my
folks moved back to Texas
um I started paying my monthly mortgage
payments a little bit less than what I
have been paying for years because I was
scared and terrified and overwhelmed for
the first time in my life
and I found out that chase sold bundles
of mortgages that were right under a
hundred thousand which mine was at the
time
to this debt collector uh by the name of
Shell point or new res he was LLC doing
business at Shell Point
long story short they're just kind of
horrible and everything that Mr Ramsey
has spoken about collection agencies and
debt collectors well they issued a
forbearance during covet I I sent them a
chunk of money ten thousand dollars
because I was a little behind
and you know I'm very nervous about
these matters and I send some money and
then they said you can take advantage of
a forbearance during all these coveted
programs that the feds were issuing so I
took a little uh forbearance break to
bury my mom and sell her childhood home
and all that kind of stuff
um go through her things alone and
whatever and um
well now this time is over and they've
come at me aggressively and I got a
letter from some cheesy law firm in Long
Island the paper looks like it's printed
out on like 1985 print out I don't even
know if it's valid but they said there's
a data sign for a foreclosure now
a couple of weeks ago let me hop in here
let me hop in here okay I can hear the
anger in your voice okay oh yeah here's
the question we have to ask okay and if
you if you've listened to me at all you
know
um I'm as empathetic as they come
okay I I can't wrap my head around
having to bury my mom and go through her
things
okay thankfully you haven't been there
yet
okay
she was young too by the way yeah yeah I
mean it's a lot
here's the question
sure did you get far enough behind on
your mortgage that you're not that chase
just did some crazy thing and what
but at some point they sold your home to
a to a bad debt collector because you
weren't paying on it is that right or is
that not right no I was paying them
every month up until and and the full
amount up until 2019 probably about six
months into 2019 when I was in between
jobs and my mom was dying and did die in
2019 by the way right before Christmas
and um so there was a period of time you
didn't pay the full amount and that
amount went to collections but I kept
paying something every month yeah but it
wasn't the agreed-upon amount in in the
in your mortgage structure right
correct well yeah of course not okay
okay so maybe I made these payments
every month and then nobody's disputing
that there's nobody's disputing that not
at all but if you told them and if you
told them if in your mortgage hey I'm
gonna pay a thousand bucks every month
and you started paying them 500 every
month
and they're gonna say hey you're not
paying your mortgage
and
um in a perfect world you would hope
somebody after 15 or 17 years of
faithful would call you and say hey
what's going on this is out of the
ordinary for you
and it's a big giant bank that probably
rolled you up in a computer program they
saw you as an account number you're just
a number you've missed yeah you missed
your payment but for three months and it
just gets shipped off there's no
discussion we're talking about it this
is not a personal attack against Sally
this was just the robot saying all right
send it to collections I know and and
you know I'm not I I I am aware of the
reality of this world and how
corporations and Banks you know who I
mean does anyone have to say anything
good about a bank no of course not I get
it but now I'm just in this place where
I need your advice on what to do who do
I contact do I follow a complaint like
um you know I just sometimes thousand
dollar check okay does that square you
up
creditor of the debt so we're going to
contact Chase and say what companies did
you authorize to collect this debt
that will give us the right information
and we're going to go to whoever's
coming at us we say I need this in
writing I need to know exactly how much
I owe what I owe all the details of this
before I even agree to talk about this
any further
okay so get that all in writing never
give them access to your checking
account never give them any personal
information be proactive you call them
more than they call you I want them to
be annoyed yeah you say hey just giving
you an update here's where here's where
things stand I saw that my thirty
thousand dollar check cleared just want
to make sure um will you send me
something right now that shows it
applied to the balance show me right now
right now right now and they may say
sorry your house is already in
foreclosure that ship sailed okay we
should have had thirty thousand dollars
last month or the month before the month
before the last year and so it may be
too late
but it's not work I want you to knock on
there like George said knock on the door
every day every day every day where are
we where are we where are we and finally
they're gonna they're gonna take a
computer inventory every time you call
and there's gonna be man this lady calls
every day twice three times a day and
hey
yes the banks and yes Corporate America
this is just a person on the other other
end of the phone treat them with dignity
and respect and kindness okay and all of
the it's so easy I'm the worst at this
my wife is often going okay cool John
glad the end of times blah blah what can
we do right now what can we do right now
and Sally you can look up the fair debt
collection practices act that protects
you and that tells them hey you can't
call me after five o'clock and you're
gonna keep track of every time you call
who you talk to what time it was every
detail of that call and you're gonna
stay on them and we're gonna clean this
mess up and we're gonna learn it uh
learn from our mistakes call it a stupid
tax and move on without anger because
your life is worth more than just
sitting there angry at a big bank for
the rest of your life so we're hoping
the best for you hope you can get this
thing cleaned up and move forward give
us a call Triple eight eight two five
five two two five this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell host of the entree
leadership podcast a fine print and
co-host of smart money happy hour join
this hour by the host of the Dr John
deloney show you guessed it America it's
Dr John deloney himself how funny would
it be if there's a different house if it
was Dan hey my name is Dan I'm hosting
the Dr John deloney show it's kind of
like us me and you hosting the Ramsey
show that's true at least Dave took his
first name off of it I think that's
awkward for all of us it's great well we
are here for you America taking your
calls about life money mental health
relationships career it all kind of
Blends into one blurry thing we call
life and we're here to help you take the
night the next step and help you make a
breakthrough in that so triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number to call Renee joins us up next in
Orlando Florida Renee welcome to the
show
hi thank you
um
so just a little bit of backstory my
husband and I were in our mid-30s and we
both work for in front line positions at
one of the major theme parks in the area
and we also have a six-year-old son and
for the last three months we've been
living in a hotel because we could no
longer afford our rent in our apartment
and financially we are just not in a
place to buy a house
um we've
been able to secure an apartment but the
real issue is
we ended up falling for
um as you would say George the stupid
tax of getting into payday loans and
installment loans and now we're like
twenty five thousand dollars in debt and
we make like 75 000 a year but between
the weekly payments on those loans and
our regular bills were suffocating under
um under our debt and we don't know how
to get out of it
um we were just turned on to your show
on the Ramsey Solutions maybe like a
couple days ago from a co-worker of mine
and we've found Hope in it so far but
we've been hearing stuff on the show
like baby steps and emergency funding we
don't know what any of that stuff is and
we just we don't know how to start we
don't know where to go from here we
don't have anything in savings we don't
have anything for retirement we don't
have anything for our kids and we would
like to have more children someday and
set up a stable future and a stable home
life for them eventually
so I'm so sorry to hear all about this
for now
gosh are you ready
like when George starts talking here
like you have to say you're ready and
what that means is you're ready to quit
your jobs if you have to you're ready to
move out of the area if you're happy
you're ready to change everything are
you in
yes we're ready Stephen my husband and I
we've already
looking into
schooling to um get different jobs
um you know stay in the jobs that we
have right now so that we can fund the
schooling that we're going to because um
the company we're at they will fund
higher education for free
um and my husband he currently has a
bachelor's in psychology and wants to go
to school for a master's of Social Work
to be a guidance counselor and I'm
looking into real estate school because
I don't have any desire to go to college
per se and throw money into a system
where there's no guarantee of me getting
a job in that field so okay so you're
ready so George is going to walk you
through it yeah so I love that you guys
want to further your education and get
out of this hole but right now we're in
survival mode and so I'm not thinking
about school I'm thinking about how are
we going to put food on the table and
stop living in hotels and make sure our
six-year-old is taken care of and so A1
is to stop going into debt are you guys
done there are you still having to take
out these payday loans to get by
no we're we're done we
we did take out some credit cards a
couple months ago but we have since
stopped using them and um can you
physically cut them up
yes cut them up and throw them away so
you don't know the numbers anymore
okay they were going to pay those off
completely and we're going to close all
of those accounts
and we're not going to look at credit
card companies and payday loans as a
blessing to get us through next week
they are snakes
okay they prey on people in your
situation okay who are working their
butts off to try to make it work and
they want the best for their little kid
and just can't make the ends meet they
prey on you they give me and George they
give us free flights and you pay for
them
okay
they are not your friend
so once we're saying no to debt let me
ask the interest on these payday loans
because I think it's going to make us
all throw up
oh too much good
is it in the hundreds
I probably I mean we're we're spending
twelve hundred dollars a month on these
payday loans what other debt do you have
um we both have car payments
and I've looked into selling them off
and we are basically upside down on both
of our cars because again it was a buy
here pay here kind of place so
astronomical interest rates okay what
other you have two car loans you got the
payday loans you have the credit cards
what else
um the credit cards were actually not in
debt on
um we we make those payments zero
balance okay we just stopped using them
um but we also have like medical bills
and collections I have maybe twelve
hundred dollars in medical bills and
Collections and my husband has
1400 in Corrections okay so what we're
going to do is A1 is we're not going
into more debt that's baby Step Zero
we're gonna stop the bleeding your next
step is to scrape together a thousand
dollars as quickly as possible that's a
that's going to go into a savings
account I know that sounds like how are
we going to do that we have no margin
and this is where we go obviously you
guys aren't living lavishly
all of your money is going to death
lavishly in a long time so right now
you're expensive haircut in a year your
expenses are your four walls is what I'm
guessing food utilities housing
transportation
and then anything like
that we are working 60 70 hour weeks and
we're trading spots to take care of the
six-year-old for a few weeks just so we
can get out from being underwater let's
tell her what that like that means he
your husband gets off of work and he
doesn't come home
yeah that's what we've been doing my
husband's been doing double shifts good
six six or seven days a week because he
can my my role at this theme park um
they don't allow overtime but have you
talked to your employer your leaders
there and explain what's going on
could they put you up in some of their
housing on the property temporarily they
don't they don't have it I mean they
have it for the college kids but do you
have somebody actual do you have
somebody who could
um
watch your kid for you
we will now because like our closest
family is three hours away
um but we recently acquired an apartment
thank god
um in a complex that's an hour away from
work but we actually have friends that
live in the complex that would be
willing to so it might be for 30 days
from time to time well it might be for
30 days you ask them tell them hey we're
in a mess and the moment you get off
you're going straight to drive Uber or
deliver ubereats or deliver instacart
and all we're trying to do is get a
thousand dollars get a thousand dollars
you're gonna get a thousand dollars in
your account and you're gonna take a
deep breath for the first time in a long
time
okay and you're gonna do whatever it
takes even if it's I'm staying with
friends I'm gonna get plugged into a
local church and do whatever you can to
get there baby step two is listing all
the debts smallest to largest regardless
of the interest rate and attacking it
with a Vengeance with all the margin you
can muster up with all the income you
can create with all the expenses you can
shave down and it might be hard at first
but when you knock out that first debt
you are going to be on cloud nine and
you're gonna feel like oh my gosh we can
do this thing and You're Gonna Knock Out
The Next Step In The Next Step what does
that do it frees up the payments on
those now giving you a bigger snowball
to keep rolling and that's called the
debt snowball method
okay and once you do that over the next
you know it may What's the total amount
of debt you guys have
um I would say between 25 and 30 000 you
guys can do this easy you make 75k you
got 25 to pay off we've heard much
smaller incomes with much bigger numbers
and they were able to do it so I want
you the key to all of this is just
believing that you can do it and we're
going to help you and walk with you by
giving you one year of Financial Peace
University watch all nine lessons with
your husband and to get fired up to give
you knowledge to give you motivation
we're going to give you one year of
every dollar premium to get on a written
plan a budget every single week you're
tracking every expense making every
dollar stretch as far as it can go
and I want you to call us back when
you're debt free and share your story
because it's going to give so many other
people out there hope who didn't think
it was possible for them hang on the
line Jenna's gonna pick up We are
rooting for you we are in your corner
please call us back if we can help in
any other way this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
what's up America welcome back to the
Ramsey Show I'm George Campbell joined
by Dr John baloney this hour
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself they're
100 satisfaction guarantee it means even
if you miss measure or pick the wrong
color they will remake your blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
with new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
Ramsay to get the best deal
all right here um today's question comes
from Britain in Georgia Britain writes
I'm 29 years old and I'm currently on
baby step two I net around 27 000 a year
and I owe 4 500 bucks in student loan
debt and 78 000 on a mortgage on a condo
that I co-signed for with my stepmom two
years ago to build my credit score
this was before I learned the
quote-unquote Ramsay way I thought going
into debt was a normal part of life I
talked to my dad and stepmom about
refinancing to get my name off the condo
and they said no because the monthly
payment and interest on the loan is so
low and they're renting out the condo to
pay their mortgage on their house if
they refinance they'll have to pay a few
hundred more a month oh
way so they're going to continue to bury
their 29 year old son so they save a
couple hundred bucks a month what a
great mom and dad wonderful way to go
dad and stepmom my question is that was
John commentary by the way my question
is I realize now that co-signing on a
mortgage wasn't a smart move ta-da on my
part and I'm wondering how this will
affect my ability to get my own mortgage
going forward if they won't refinance
and if they won't refinance what should
my next step be
what a pickle we found ourselves in
Brenton what a pickle well uh I'm glad
we've we've learned the lesson here and
this is going to be a hard conversation
with Mom and Dad saying hey my future's
on the line here and I regret this
decision and I want out and this is part
of the risk of co-signing because guess
what you could stop paying yeah and
guess who that mortgage would fall on
your parents so you say we can do this
the hard way or we could do this the
easy way
the easy way is you allow me to
refinance and you figure out how to
cover a few hundred extra bucks a month
on the small mortgage so that I can live
my adult life because I am broke I net
27 Grand a year I'm in student loan debt
I need to get out
and uh I hope that works right I mean
there's I don't know that you can force
it you can talk to
um you know Churchill Mortgage they'll
explain the deal when it comes to debt
to income ratio and the timelines and
when you would be able to buy a house if
this is still sitting uh on you but I
would do my best to get out of this and
I do I I George I don't know
oh here's what I want you to check on
Britain I think if you called an
attorney
you were you were basically dissolving a
partnership here if you co-sign on a
loan and if you say I want out of this
partnership and my partner refuses to
let me out I think I may be wrong
because this may just be a business
transaction but I think you can take
them to court and the judge will force a
sale
and they force a sale and then you split
the proceeds and purchase in a pear tree
because my guess is that this place also
has Equity into it that you've bought
into over the last two years and the
house is probably the the house has
probably gone way up the condo is
probably escalated in value
significantly in Georgia and so you've
got money built into this thing even
just walking away from it as a gift to
your dad and stepmom who just love you
so much that they want to keep you tied
to this thing but you can force it I
think George brings up a good point we
can do this the hard way or the easy way
the easy way is I need y'all to sign
this over the hard way is I refuse to be
held back in my life by a decision I
made when I was 25 years old I screwed
up I'm sorry
um but I want to move on with this and
at the end of the day here's what's
gonna be hard your parents may choose
that couple hundred dollars a month over
a relationship with their son they might
make that choice
and that says more about them than it
does you so if you have to say okay cool
I learned my lesson I will never co-star
on anything ever ever again and by the
way
I'm sorry that y'all walked away from
your son over a couple hundred bucks a
month good grief and by the way Britain
twenty seven thousand dollars a year at
age 29.
you're gonna have to make some more
money man you're gonna make some money
that's not a judgment statement that is
me saying I love you enough to that I
see your value in you that you don't see
and I want you to put yourself in a
better financial position at 29 so that
when you're ready to buy a house you got
the money to do so yeah that's a good
call and you don't have to lean on
schemes and hey man will you help me out
to build a credit score right yeah the
good news is you being a homeowner is
not anytime in the near future with this
level of debt and income and so it's
going to be a while anyways uh now you
can still get the info I would still do
your homework talk to an estate attorney
you can talk to Churchill Mortgage and
they can give you the rundown on what
that looks like with debt to income
ratio but right now what you wouldn't
qualify for a mortgage as it stands so I
I wish you the best in getting out of
the situation man it's just one of the
many reasons we tell you never to
co-sign debt and never have a mortgage
with someone you're not married to yes
it's just messy and it hurts
relationships every time all right
thanks for the question yeah thanks man
all right let's go to the phones Mike
joins us in NYC Mike welcome to the show
hey guys how are you thanks so much for
having me uh about a year listener
awesome you guys have you guys have
created a gazelle on steroids wow stop
paying down debt due to gazelle New
Yorker man that's that's somebody to be
reckoned with I'm scared of that
I have a question for you guys all right
I recently I recently came into some
money through the uh sale of my mother's
house
has anyone ever and I do have three
children young children has anyone ever
skipped five and six because I really
want to land a knockout punch
on my mortgage I mean it's the type of
punch that when like Rocky hit drag oh
he's cut you got the momentum I have the
money now he's not a machine he's a man
yeah I know what's up so you're saying
skip five and knock out six which is pay
off the house early
and then with the and then it'll bring
my mortgage down to about seven years so
essentially I'm refinancing without
refinancing
um get out of that and reallocate my
mortgage payment
for my you know I'd like pretend I have
a mortgage payment and that would fund
my kids education so I have the money
now I'm eager to keep paying down debt
and I can't be stopped so what's what's
left on the mortgage
right now at this point 356. and how
much money do you have
um
uh around 250 but I know I have to save
some for um some taxes my accountant
said with the light because it was under
a life estate yeah so I know I have to
save some money so let's say I want to
throw 200 at my mortgage and get it down
to one don't refinance it at that point
no he's saying that by putting 200 he's
basically getting a refinance got it
basically a company where are you at
with it with the kids you said they're
young how old are they uh nine six and
four okay and how much do you have saved
for college right now
nothing we we never got into a five to
nine plan because like I said we were we
had to start the baby steps so over the
last 20 months 25 months we've got to
step five now so okay so you've been
investing fifteen percent you've got the
fully funded emergency fund and you're
out of all Consumer Debt last thing is
the mortgage how much do you make
uh household income is a little shy of
210. okay
well I think we split the difference
here I don't think it needs to be one or
the other why don't we throw a bunch of
money in a 529 plan or an Esa maybe you
could fully fund an Esa for each kid
that's two grand a kid and we can put
the rest onto the mortgage so that's 198
194.
on the mortgage
oh my mortgage now is 356. so if even
right through 100 that would be 256 but
that would probably John's saying if you
had 200 and you put six of that in the
esas maybe you could even put a little
in a 529 the rest can go to the mortgage
and it's not one or the other then we're
at least starting this process because
that money is going to grow tax-free
until they're at College age
and so when you start to do the math on
that there's a lot of opportunity cost
in not starting to invest for college
right now
and the only time I've seen this if if
you think okay if we did this I would
have this mortgage paid off in a year
I'd have this mortgage paid off in 18
months
then I could be convinced
does that make sense what I don't want
it to happen it turned into oh it's
become two years and then three years
and then five years and then seven years
and suddenly that nine-year-old is 17.
right I and I definitely fact that in so
maybe we could like you said split the
difference
um but like I said I can't stop paying
debt I love it I got you man it's a lot
of fun man only for a little while
longer that's right I love it that's
right well you can do you can definitely
do both and if you knock that mortgage
down to let's say you know close to 150
160 making 210 that thing's gonna be
gone and what three four years if you're
still intense about it yeah if you're
keeping a maniac about it and then your
kids are still young and now you don't
have a mortgage payment now we can
really start shoveling money into
college savings and watching that money
grow so either way you're gonna get
there I just don't want you to to put it
all in one and forget about the sweet
kids forget about it there we go thanks
for the call Mike this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
we know a lot of you are planning on
moving soon and I've got some great news
for you our new studio sponsor pods and
moving and storage wants to help one of
you move for free all you have to do is
get a quote at pods.com Ramsay between
October 3rd and October 14th to enter to
win it's that simple one listener is
going to get a free move or a free
storage rental up to a five thousand
dollar value that's one less thing to
worry about with your move and pause
makes moving easier with the flexibility
you need the control you want and the
customer service you deserve if you're
looking for a company that will help you
move on your terms pods is the only
Ramsay trusted moving provider out there
so head to pods.com Ramsay and enter to
win free moving or Storage Rental today
that's pods.com
Ramsay open phones this hour at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
I'm George Campbell hanging out with Dr
John deloney today Madeline joins us in
Roanoke Virginia Adeline how are you
I'm great thank you guys also yeah I
want to thank you guys so much for what
you do I want to say the show is awesome
and I also love reading um the email
blast because those actually help a lot
oh that means the world our email
marketers appreciate that they work hard
on those
those are great
um yeah so my question
um but we're also maxing out my Roth IRA
at the same time
um so I'm asking is can we use the money
we haven't invested in my Roth um so
there's money in my Roth that's not
invested as a second emergency fund so
that we can keep building our emergency
fund and our Roth at the same time
assume when we don't end up using our
emergency savings from the Roth account
if you follow and then also
um or should we just take all the cash
out of my Roth and put it in the bank
um with the main emergency fund and stop
maxing out until we've completed baby
step three you took the words right out
of my mouth
why haven't you been doing that one the
whole time I feel like there's a reason
um taking all the cash out of the and
following the baby steps as laid out
which means we're not investing until we
have the fully funded emergency fund you
guys are doing yeah three things at once
yeah no we'll we we're not doing that I
guess just because I was when I was 17
my dad set me up with investing and I
never stopped maxing out so it's just
not like I've I didn't have debt at the
time so we cruised through some baby
steps while we were maxing out so got it
well um we're here today so let me let's
walk you through what's next so how far
are you from having a fully funded
emergency fund
[Music]
um
probably
like five thousand dollars away a little
more than that okay and how much is in
the cash portion of your Roth IRA
um about three thousand dollars oh a
cash portion of the Roth IRA that's five
thousand dollars I'm sorry oh so you
have three thousand invested and five
thousand is just sitting on the
sidelines that you can move anywhere
yeah so what you just told me is you
have a fully funded emergency fund way
to go Madeline congratulations so just
move the money over to your savings not
exactly but we're trying to yeah we're
trying to get up to fourteen thousand
dollars you have three thousand dollars
in the bank and we have five thousand
dollars
in
um the Roth okay so that puts you at
eight you need to get to 14. yeah like
six thousand more okay yeah and so how
long is it gonna take for us to get six
thousand more if we're pausing investing
for now
um it's gonna go faster isn't it yeah
it's gonna go a lot faster yeah and then
I guess another part of that question is
should we be saving for retirement
before we're done saving for our first
house is that like
also part of the equation so you're
talking about 3B which is saving for the
down payment and baby step four that one
is a Choose Your Own Adventure depending
on your age and how quickly you want to
get into a house and where you're at for
retirement some people choose to do up
to the match and the rest is going to a
down payment some people choose to pause
investing for two years and stock up
that down payment some people choose to
do 15 and it's going to be a longer
journey to get the down payment and so
it just depends on where you guys are at
in life
absolutely thanks for the call good
question it was I mean it was like
Beautiful Mind level math in the
beginning there and it just when you
simplify it it changes things if you're
listening to this Georgia said the word
simple
I was a guy that had a bank account for
our emergency fund a bank account for
our bills a bank account to get
automatically withdrawn from just in
case it gets overdrawn because they've
got our number I had another account
there was like a secret storage and you
know what I caused a huge mess a giant
mess like an open field open Real
open-faced fishing reel that I cast
backwards it's just a huge nest of mess
and my wife was like hey there's this
cool thing in our One Bank
it's got multiple accounts you can open
just in the same account can we just do
that and that way I don't want to set
myself on fire every time I ask how much
anyway simple simple simple that is the
answer to most of our money problems
simplifying relationship problems most
of our problems simplify good word all
right we're going to Charlotte North
Carolina up next Chris joins us there
Chris welcome to the show
hey how's it going today good how are
you
doing pretty good can't complain so I
started watching the material about a
week ago I'm on baby step two and as I'm
looking at my budget and my bills I
realized that I had my phone bill and my
insurance premiums should I include that
into babysat 2 or do I leave that off to
the side and making monthly payments
well what do you actually owe debt on
because your insurance premiums Aren't
Dead correct that's just a monthly it's
like a utility bill
right it's not necessarily dead but it
is something that I'm I'm going to have
to pay one way or another so that's why
I'm a little confused of sure you're
gonna have to pay maybe I should be
included so my only debt is the two
credit cards at 500 another credit card
had a thousand and uh motorcycle in the
car but that's above so I'm thinking
maybe I should just kind of pay off my
credit cards first then do the phone and
the insurance then pay off my motorcycle
or just pay them off smallest balance to
largest balance and ignore the interest
rate
okay and your insurance let me explain
how that would work so you're doing a
budget hopefully
and in your budget you're going to have
a sinking fund and you can create that
with every dollar they have a special
you Market as a sinking fund and so what
you would do is if your insurance bill
is let's say 1200 bucks a year that's
100 a month so in your budget you're
going to have a line item for insurance
at 100 a month and that hundred dollars
is going to stay in your checking your
savings account so by the end of the
year after 12 months of that you have
twelve hundred dollars ready to pay that
bill
so we're not going to put that in the
debt snowball section and then as far as
your phone your phone payments you're
saying you have payments on your phone
because that's how they sell phones
these days because they want to keep us
in debt
yeah it's in the contract and all that
type of stuff so if you stop paying that
payment what are they going to do
they're going to come after you right
right so I would consider that debt and
include that in your debt snowball to
parse out the phone payment and if you
can pay it off in full find out the
amount you owe on the phone if it's 900
bucks we're gonna put that in the debt
snowball and get that phone that phone
paid off in full
okay
um well it's not necessarily a phone
it's more the service for it so I don't
think I could pay off the services no
the service is just like your monthly
bill so it'd be like you're like a water
bill yeah yeah and so just put that in
your monthly budget as a line item
separately and if you're using every
dollar uh which if are you not using it
right now or using a separate method
oh no I'm sorry what was that are you
using our every dollar budgeting tool
are you doing budgeting differently
uh no I have every dollar allocated to
something okay well we have an app
called every dollar I'm gonna gift that
to you for one year the premium version
to connect to your bank so you can drag
the transactions in it makes it really
easy to create those syncing funds I
mentioned it makes it easy to track all
of your debt in one place we have our
own baby steps tracker where you can
track your debt snowball to keep the
momentum going so hang on the line and
we're going to gift that to you for
being one of our listeners and want to
get on this plan but uh it's that simple
if it's debt then it's going to go in
the debt snowball if it's not it just
becomes a line item in the budget hey
and man one of the strangest looks I've
received in my lifetime and I've
received a few is when I went to I think
it was at T or whatever and I said hey I
need a new phone how much does it cost
and they're like well we'll just sign up
on plan and put it I was like I don't
know I just want to buy a phone
and he's like uh hold on and then they
like a manager comes over and it's like
oh what do you want and I was like I
just want to pay for this phone like
well we'll just roll it into a plan oh
and I was like I get that but I just
want to buy this phone I don't like
owing people money this is before I work
here this is back in Texas and finally
the salesman they figured it all out and
he came back and said no one has ever
asked this question and I said what and
he goes no one's ever asked can I just
buy this phone that's frightening and uh
they had to come up with a special plan
on how I could just walk out with my own
phone by giving them money how can how
can we figure this out that's how we can
train my money all of America today is
well what's the monthly payment yes
great I can do that yep absolutely oh my
goodness what a time to be alive John
good hour thank you sir thank you to all
the folks in the booth we got Jenna will
Austin Andrew keeping the show afloat in
you America thank you so much for
listening who else is back there we got
Bobby back he's an engineer fan yeah we
don't need to mention him yeah we'll be
back with you before you know it folks
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
what is up America this is the Ramsay
show broadcasting from the PODS moving
and storage studios here in Nashville
Tennessee this is where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
money your life your relationships your
mental health your work all of it
whatever's going on in your life we're
here for you triple eight eight two five
five two two five I'm John deloney
joined here by my good friend George
camel and we're taking your calls it's a
toll-free call Money life anything you
got going on Triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go out to
Jessica in Huntsville Alabama what's up
Jessica
hey Georgia John I'm so excited to talk
to you guys
um are you calling to ask us who you who
we think is going to win this weekend
between Alabama and UT it's going to
probably be UT but go ahead we already
know who's going to win actually
oh okay I see what we're doing here all
right
before you throw a ball back and forth
Jessica gets me she gets me she really
gets me George has no idea what we're
talking about literally I was like I
can't believe John knows that that's so
cool he knows when the big game's
happening and by the way what's the
beginning for the first episode of man
mentor to come out yes this is when John
coaches me up and shows me how to change
oil on my Tesla oh yeah we've talked
about the idea of having a show where I
teach George how to do things that most
men already know how to do I know and I
showed John how to get past his
insecurities which are strong and quite
strong yes that that's going to be a
great huge huge success how can we
actually be helpful today Jessica yeah
um
so we were we are going to make 200
000 this year
um and probably more next year
we're on baby step two and we have 225
000 in student loan debt are you a
doctor um
we're both Masters and doctorate
training nurses okay very cool yeah so
um and then we have our cars they're
both paid off worth probably 80 to 90
both so
um so and one is a Tesla so should we
sell our cars
uh okay so I mean on a financial like on
paper there's nothing wrong with you
guys having ninety thousand dollars
worth of cars when you make 200 and it's
paid for and so selling one of these
cars doesn't free up a payment it will
accelerate your debt-free journey but
there's no reason you guys can't be debt
free within two or three years
completely even with this level of debt
so the question is how that's the goal
if you want to sell one because you're
like well you don't really need it we
don't love this car obviously you're
going to sell the non-tesla vehicle I am
at Jessica listen I know the uh my
husband probably is like why are you
calling them right now no listen
um as somebody who's sitting next to
George and I have a regular self-esteem
I would sell both of these cars
um that's just me like that I'd sell
both of the cars I would buy two ten
thousand dollar cars and I would take
the 60 to 70 000 and knock this debt out
y'all make too much money to be this
broke for the next three years there's
no reason to do it and you are faking
pseudo fantasy Happiness by driving to
work every day and dude I would buy
Tesla tomorrow if I could afford one I
love them I love I'm literally jealous
of George's car no kidding
um but I I'm not there yet
and so I'm not gonna live in a fantasy
world well I still I'm not gonna drive a
75 000 car when I still have a mortgage
and it's not going to do it and so I
would sell both the cars
um and buy two Corollas and let that be
the gas the jet engine fuel that you
need to get yourself out of debt
that's what I would do okay George would
not do that yeah well I know I think to
John's point on paper we're not going to
yell at you and say oh my gosh this is
ridiculous I just think it's going to be
a lot harder to pay off 225 000 in debt
in two years even making 200 if there's
not some level of sacrifice yeah
um we don't talk about this enough
George and Jessica it's hard um there's
an old adage in boxing
which is it's hard when you've had your
big payday when you're a multi-multi
multi-millionaire it's really hard to
get up at 5am and go for a run and jump
rope and then go to the gym and get
punched in the face because you have a
million dollars in your bank account
it is very hard to get gazelle intents
and pay off two hundred thousand dollars
with the debt when you're cruising in a
Tesla it just is it's really easy when
you're driving and my 06 Tundra that I
love with all my heart and she is I'm
duct taping her together at this point
it's really easy for me to get that
mortgage paid off right to to grind and
grind and grind because I'm tired of
driving this car see what I'm saying
yes I get it and that's why another
reason I think the thousand dollar
emergency fund is so important too
because it makes you sweat and that's
all you're working with yeah it makes
you fun a little bit are you guys down
to a thousand dollars in the emergency
fund are you really doing this
no how much money do you guys have
[Applause]
three times
the budget because we're bi-weekly paid
so I keep my money for the next months
and then pull it over and there's
probably about two to three thousand
okay are you guys yeah that's fine are
you guys doing any investing right now
no okay cool
well that should help I mean making 200
the question is how much of that can we
throw at the debt and if we can sell one
or both cars how much faster is that
going to speed up the process how many
paychecks of working our tails off uh
would that cover to sell these cars and
so when you put it on paper like that it
changes the conversation with with your
husband when you go oh my gosh this is
seven months of busting our tails and we
can Propel our journey forward by
selling these and there's going to be
cars on the other side yeah they will
always sell more cars and we will
continue to have an amazing income with
no debt George and I talked about that
on another show the other day the more
I'm around people who have
significant wealth the more I realize
they are spending their money on the
single most precious resource on the
planet and that's time
and so if you just do a simple time
calculation what's it going to take how
many months would it take us to pay off
ninety thousand dollars those cars are
worth nothing and then you look at those
little kids I hear in the background and
you say you know what we're willing to
cash out another year of your life
living like this paycheck to paycheck
paying off our debts because we really
love our fancy cars it's it's a
no-brainer and you get a cool story to
tell your kids like we used to drive
these fancy cars and we sold them so
that we could become debt free that's
right like Mom just passed the Cheerios
exactly
well played you're you're your time is
not worth the car and and make no
mistake because people are gonna on the
YouTubes are gonna be like he's gonna
sell your nah that's what I'm saying I'd
buy a Tesla tomorrow I'd buy a nice
truck tomorrow I just have different
goals and my goals involve sleeping
really well at night and not worrying
about whether we're gonna have food and
not worried about the next fill in the
blank right I'd rather not worry about
those things um I'd rather buy my time
back and also Teslas are going for
insane amounts of money right now so
good time to sell
you're probably gonna make more than you
you purchased it for I'm guessing
um about the same probably there we go
2018 model three yeah oh sweet which is
cool about a 2018. I can't tell the
difference between that and 2022 13 my
friend
gangster they all Rachel's accidentally
tried to break into my car the other day
and I was like I'm winning
I'm winning
she had no clue mine was way older
good times you got to be uncomfortable
you got to be uncomfortable get
yourselves out of debt get yourselves
out of debt we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
825-5225 this is the Ramsey Show I'm
John deloney joined here by George
Campbell hey we're celebrating the one
year anniversary of borrowed Futures
launch by premiering the film on YouTube
that is a sentence that didn't exist
several years ago but here we are we're
premiering the film on YouTube on Monday
October 17th at 7 pm Central with a
watch party
borrowed a few I said that like I'm 111
years old they're gonna throw a big
who had a showdown but we're gonna have
a hoot Nanny on
listen borrowed future is our
award-winning documentary that uncovers
the dark side of the student loan
industry we believe every high schooler
and parent of high schoolers should
watch this film and my higher ed
colleague should watch this film as well
so share this with someone you know that
needs it following the watch party uh
Throwdown on October 17th you can view
borrowed future on YouTube for free on
demand the film is still available on
Amazon Prime video Apple TV Google Play
and ramseysolutions.com where you can
rent it ad free let's continue to
disrupt the toxic student loan industry
join us Monday night for our borrowed
future watch party on the YouTubes you
can RSVP on the Ramsay shows YouTube
channel for a reminder all right let's
go to Michelle in Burlington Coat
Factory Vermont what's up Michelle
good how are you good how are you
I'm doing good I'm here
um that's outstanding so what's up
yeah okay so I'm on baby step number two
and I have
322 of debt left oh you are so close
but um before I started this journey I
agreed to go on a two-week two-part kind
of vacation and then I also started a
new job so I won't have PT uh PTO
so I started stopped with my debt
journey to stop paying off the debt and
I have 5 362 in my savings but every
time I look
at that ratio I just kind of kills me
that I can't pay it off am I doing the
right thing
okay so you have you agree to go on a
vacation who did you agree to go on this
vacation with
the first week it's a family trip to
Florida and then this
it's my friend's bachelorette party
which I'm in the wedding okay and
combined those vacations are going to
cost you about five grand
because I also wanted to
um think about like monthly expenses for
the two weeks of work I'll be missing
and not getting paid for out okay so all
that combined is five thousand bucks
I'm hoping to get another I'm hoping to
get it to six
thousand just to be on the safe side
okay
so a couple of things here number one
you you agreed to this vacation in a
family you agreed to be in this in your
friend's wedding and then they laid all
these expenses out and then you got a
new job
yeah okay so
as far as I'm concerned you got a new
job and that that is life outside of
vacation so if my if I had a friend that
was going to be in my wedding and he
called and said dude I lost my other job
I got laid off I took a new job I got no
paid time off
um I'm not going to be able to come on
the week-long blowout we were gonna do
I'd be like oh it's a bummer dude and he
would say I know man but I'll be there
for the wedding I'll be there for the
rehearsal dinner and all that and I
would be completely fine with that
and if I had a family event planned and
my little brother called and said hey I
got a new job I'm not going to be able
to make it we got I'm starting I would
say dude congratulations on getting a
new job so that's just me so as far as
I'm concerned I don't have any problem
with you reaching out to your family as
an Integrity interesting I got a new job
I don't have time off and I'm not in a
position right now to not get paid
the other side of that is
um every single one of my jobs including
the one I have now
I I live my life with SP I've been
speaking at places for years and so I've
got things on the calendar four months
six months sometimes nine months in
advance every single job I've had I've
come in saying hey I've already got
these things on the calendar is that
okay
and every single job I've taken they
have been like absolutely no problem
come on in
so I don't know if you've done that
already with your supervisor or sit down
and say hey I already had these on the
calendar when I took this and I should
have brought this up and I didn't but if
you think that would be a safe
conversation to have I would try that
too that way you're not losing that
money also
so they do know I have these vacations
planned and they're giving me the time
off but since I'm an hourly employee oh
they're just not paying you for it okay
yeah they're giving you permission to
choose to not get paid for two weeks
they're very nice
okay
how lovely so what is what's the hourly
pay
uh about 25 an hour okay and when are
these trips happening
uh
first week of November
all of it it's back to back yeah yes I
basically fly out of Florida to Arizona
and you've already bought the flights
yeah okay is that part of this 5000 that
you said
how much this is already paid for
yep
okay oh um the the hotels and the
flights you've already paid for those
yes but you're still thinking you're
gonna need all that money yeah what are
you spending what are you gonna do
um
I don't know if I have nieces and
nephews so I know I'm going to want to
like
We're Not Gonna spoil them when we're
broke no you don't you're broke honey
your time is what they want you don't
have the money
they want you to jump around in a pool
and throw them around someone else can
buy them ice cream yes
okay
so if I'm in if I'm in your shoes and
all this is paid for I'm gonna be debt
free today today
and I'm gonna figure out how to go spend
time with my family without trying to
buy their affection and if you don't
have the money you just tell them sorry
guys can't go out to eat tonight you'll
have fun and if they go hey we'll cover
your meal it's no big deal we go that's
so nice and you accept the generosity
and that's it and you take a flashlight
and you take the kids out and y'all go
catch sand crabs and it will be the
adventure of a lifetime and they won't
remember the whirly gig you bought them
for fourteen dollars but they will
remember the time you got pinched on the
finger and you yelled a bad word and you
ran around like they'll remember those
things figure that out
is that cool
yes you are broke and you're about to be
debt free Tada what are you doing in
Arizona what do you have to pay for
um
I going out to dinner
um I think whenever we go out okay
and then there's like a wine tour
um
so bad stuff
I would be as conservative as you
possibly can be on that and I would be
really open because these are your ride
or dies these are your friends you're
close to them you all love each other
that you all are in each other's
weddings I would let them know I am
tired of being broke and I am getting
myself out of debt and so I'm gonna come
on the trip I'm gonna have dinner I'm
not pitching on the Ave on the appetizer
this time I'm drinking water I'm gonna
be that I'm gonna blame I know lame I
know I know I'll go to the wine tasting
I've already put in 300 bucks for that
I'm gonna go to that that's fine
um
but we're not I I'm gonna be smart about
this I'm not gonna use this is a time to
just go off the rails here's why you're
broke
you can't afford it and I know like I
know I want to I know I I want it for
you but you're broke
and future Michelle is going to love
present Michelle exactly right going oh
my gosh I just got back from the trip
and I'm debt free yes and I've got a new
job and now I can focus on building the
emergency fund and living my life and
starting to invest and do all these
things and you're not having to carry
this debt around for who knows how much
longer because we blew it all the nieces
nephews and Wine Tours think of future
Michelle think of present Michelle and
future Michelle ah here's a magic line
choose guilt over resentment every time
choose the guilt you feel over not
buying a bunch of stuff
a bunch of junk for kids they're gonna
it's gonna be gone to be thrown away in
the next two or three months anyway
choose the guilt over the resentment of
I don't want to hang out with them
because I'm broke
choose the guilt over telling your
friends hey I'm not pitching in on this
super Atomic
I'm not I'm not doing the pedal tavern
in downtown that's just a wise decision
always always I'm not doing it I don't
want to be on a pedal Tavern I'm not
doing it
um
choose guilt over the resentment you're
going to feel when you're sweating
drinking whatever three yard beers
you've got and you're all annoyed that
you didn't want to do this in the first
place you're going to present to
everybody choose guilt over resentment
choose it every time should tweet that
that's good well I didn't come up with
it so oh never mind hey this is the
Ramsay show triple eight eight two five
five two two five we'll be right back
here
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsey Show let's go
out to George in Tampa Florida what's up
George
hey guys thanks for taking the call you
got it what's up man you want to pick
your brain about uh if I'm on baby step
two or three here's my situation I have
a house that I owe 370 000 on for about
575 and uh we just moved into this house
bought it six months ago our electric
bill is astronomical our last electric
bill is 600 for the month
so we ended up investing in solar panels
our solar panel loan is a total a
hundred thousand we pay
326 dollars a month on the solar panel
payments so my question is should I
treat the solar panel payment as just
kind of part of if I would normally pay
the utility company every month and and
not really consider it a debt and focus
more on paying off the house early
or should I consider the solar panel
payment which again we owe a hundred
thousand on as a Consumer Debt and try
to pay that off as quickly as possible
it's absolutely a Consumer Debt
okay no six way half dozen ways about it
and I did that wrong but you know what I
mean it's not a debt um I would change
the word now listen I've I have a I live
out here in the woods in Tennessee I
have a
um I've had an engineer come out and
draw me out where the solar panels would
be what they'll cost how they'll be
installed so it's on my on my purchase
list I'm a fan of them okay
um but I think it's honest at this point
in the solar panel World
um to say use the word investment is a
way you're trying to lessen the pain of
a hundred thousand dollar Consumer Debt
you just took on
okay so I would treat as a hundred
thousand bucks yes it could be saving on
your electric bill great
um but to look at as an investment is
not the right way to do it I'd pay it
off as soon as possible
okay so Jordan's on that before paying
off the mortgage yes absolutely let me
ask you one more question here what is
the interest on that loan
on the solar panel it's
1.99 and so it's you know our mortgage
is 4.375 so I thought was well if I pay
the house off faster you know I could
start throwing that at these solar
panels but but what happens if you have
a paid for house and you owe 78 000 on
your solar panels and you got to sell
your house
well if we sell our house and we would
pay off the solar loan with
you know we pay off that 78 000 from the
proceeds of selling a house what was
their pitch when they sold you on a
hundred thousand dollar solar loan
uh it wasn't any of their pitch it was
it was mine like I said our electric
bill was six hundred dollars in one
month and that's you know we have all
the insulation everything we had an
energy audit everything was right it's
just uh let me let me break this down
for you from a break even analysis
standpoint so your electric bill was
high you know it's obviously summertime
but now we're heading into the winter so
what would you say the average is if you
averaged it out over the course of a
year what would your bill be per month
well we've been in the house for six
months and the average has been over
five hundred dollars
okay we haven't had a winter there
though
no so it's going to go down
yeah the answer is the answer is yes
let's say the average is 400 bucks a
month over the course of the Year sure
all right that's 4 800 a year you took
out a hundred thousand dollar loan with
interest let's just say a hundred
thousand for easy numbers divide that by
the 4 800 you save a year it's going to
take you 21 years to break even on this
purchase
um okay let me ask you again is it worth
saving the 500 600 a month
if it's going to take 21 years how old
are you George
35.
you're going to be
56 years old by the time this was a good
purchase
and that's right about the time you'll
be replacing the solar panels further
and that's if you still live there the
chances are you're probably going to
move in the next decade or so right
people move all the time
uh yeah I don't know let's probably be
our forever home yeah there's no such
thing and the other thing the house did
not increase in value by a hundred
thousand dollars did it
yeah no that was rhetorical yeah the
answer is no so listen don't don't
forget man George drives a Tesla I've
got solar panels in my queue we're all
about it we just we just want to be
honest about what we're talking I'm not
I'm not trying to beat you up over this
I just I know it's easy to justify these
things because you're looking at the
electric bill and you're angry going oh
my God it's 600 a month I'll do anything
to not pay this and by anything I mean
go a hundred thousand dollars into debt
to uh rid myself of this pain so all
that to say get rid of this debt as soon
as possible there's no easy way to do it
it's on the house now we can't just I
wish you this is the 30-day return
window on solar panels that would be
amazing okay I'm sorry that one's in
there I'm sorry you got to pay the price
man but just pay it off like a Consumer
Debt then attack the house that's right
hey right now is the time of the year
when it's make or break when it comes to
our goals we're heading into holiday
season and let's be real
it's hard to stay motivated it's getting
colder it's hard to get out of bed it's
getting darker you just want to go to
bed we all have goals whether it's to
find a better job make more money pay
off debt build stronger relationships
and it can be hard to keep momentum
going but here is the good news coming
up in a couple of weeks we have one of
our biggest events smart conference
we're headed to Dallas for a day-long
jam-packed event where you'll get advice
from leading experts on money personal
growth career mental health and your
marriage you'll leave with all the
knowledge and motivation you need to
reach your goals and live the life you
want join me and the rest of the Ramsay
personalities Dave Ramsey Ken Coleman
Christina Ellis Rachel Cruz even they're
even letting George Campbell speak we're
excited got the invite to get a plan for
your money relationships personal growth
and career join us live in person on
October 22nd to get your passes before
they sell out visit ramseysolutions.com
events to get your tickets
today all right let's go to Rebecca in
Joplin Missouri what's up Rebecca
how are you partying how about you
I'm hiding for my children in the
classroom at their schools we're being
honest but it's fine I love this
fantastic all right so what's up hey my
husband is a family practice doctor a
large hospital system moved us to a
rural area for him to cover their clinic
and their hospitals the clinic was
incredibly mismanaged and as a result
the hospital system went through and
closed all of the clinics
um so a free place took them over we've
got these benefits with this free place
there is zero employer satisfaction
um they he has a 70-minute commute
there's no opportunity for growth they
have told him in writing that we don't
care about provider satisfaction in the
meantime old employer has resurfaced and
said Hey listen we're so sorry we want
you back
but we're kind of hesitant and they've
offered more money
um but there's a non-compete and so
we're trying to decide what is the
wisest choice for our family
what was
businesses close businesses open all
that kind of stuff if Dave came to me
tomorrow and said hey we are having
money problems we're going to have to
let you go
and he came and did it with Integrity I
would be upset I'd be sad I'd be like
man I didn't know this was so bad blah
blah blah and then if you came back a
year later and said hey I'd like to hire
hire you for a new Venture behind closed
doors he has proven to be himself a
person of integrity and I know he cares
about me and my family and I know
business happened in between that and
I'm okay with it so my question is not
like what happened why did they have to
close but it is how was the
interpersonal relationship did they
treat were they honest with you they
treat you with dignity business happened
fine did they treat you honestly and
with Integrity during that transition
okay however
are they looking they came back and they
said listen we have made a mistake we
have egg on our face we accept
responsibility you know here's what
we're offering
um so that has been good the part of the
change is they are offering an increase
in the clinic salary but the hospital
salary would decrease by essentially
that same amount so we would be gaining
less commute we would be gaining an
opportunity for growth but at the
expense of he does not have a
non-compete currently and he would
they absolutely will not negotiate the
non-compete it's non-negotiable sure
well you're gonna have to you're gonna
have to figure out what's right for your
family when it comes to those type of
things what I this is the devil you
don't know with the w do the double you
do know is your employer looked at you
and said I don't care how much your life
sucks we're gonna make our money and if
my employer does that I am out on the
first train out I'm out of there man
because my my marriage in my life isn't
worth that job and so sounds like it's a
good deal and yes it's going to come
with some with some sticky points to it
but that's what I would do trust your
gun on that one yeah we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
scripture of the day is Proverbs 15 1. a
gentle answer turns away wrath but a
harsh word stirs up anger the great
Victor Frankel says the one thing
you can't take away from me is the way I
choose to respond to what you do to me
that I think is the single most
important message in the world today
there's not many quotes that I would
consider a life-changing quote
transformational you choose who hurts
you
the one thing you can't take away from
me is the way I choose to respond to
what you do to me that makes you
invincible it literally is a superpower
the ability to be calm when somebody
else is angry in your presence the
ability to walk away and say I'm worth
more than this the ability to say I want
to be in relationship with you but I
refuse to be belittled like this I
refuse to work at a place that treats me
like this I'm going to pursue other
opportunities
the one thing you can't take away from
me you take away my livelihood you can
take away my life you can take away my
family you take away everything you
cannot take from me the way I choose to
respond to what you do to me powerful
powerful words from the great Victor
Frankel love it all right let's go out
to Jessica in Cincinnati Ohio what's up
Jessica
hey there um thank you so much for
taking my call absolutely thanks for
calling
I'm currently on baby step two and I'm
in the process of taking care of some
pretty decently large Consumer Debt that
I had accrued while I struggled with
some depression in the last couple of
years but my issue is that with making
some of the necessary sacrifices that
I've had to make I've gotten a lot of
flack from some friends and family for
saying no to going out and then they'll
offer to pay for me just so I do get out
so how do I start to assert those
boundaries because it makes me really
uncomfortable when they offer to pay
yeah you two two ways forward okay
number one
coming out of a depression a depressive
season and getting well you that's an
agreement with your body that we're
gonna feel this discomfort and we're
gonna head into it not away from it okay
so saying no saying I can't make it and
having somebody say I want you here so
bad because we like you that I'll just
grab your the cost of your meal and that
shame that discomfort that I'm not worth
that I'm not enough they're just pitying
me those are feelings that we are going
to for the first time we're gonna feel
them actually
we may write them down
we may look at them and demand evidence
from am I are they really asking me to
come out and pay for my meal because
they Pity Me are they really just feel
sorry for me or am I their friend and
they see that their friend like so what
dude I'm just gonna grab your meal I'd
much rather have you hang out than have
twenty dollars burning a hole in my
wallet and so the first thing is you're
going to have to begin to feel those
feelings discomfort that's the key to
getting healthy okay walking through
little tiny steps through those feelings
the second thing is you're gonna have to
make peace with missing something
sometimes and not being so prideful
that you skip out on friendships just
because you don't want to have their
help see what I'm saying
yeah I do I think it's worth going out
sometimes and letting them grab your
food for you and by the way when when I
had a friend who was struggling deeply
with depression you know what I felt
most of the time completely helpless
and being able to grab dinner was like
something I could do
and so even if you don't like the idea
of somebody paying for your dinner or
grabbing your movie ticket
think of it as a gift to your friend
I'm helping them out by letting them
help me you know what I mean because it
gives them something to do because they
love you and they want to be a part of
your recovery they just don't know how
to do it they don't they're not the
training or the professional whatever
they can give you 20 bucks to grab some
fajitas it's some nachos you know what I
mean
yeah I do
um and and for the friendships I think
that makes a lot of sense but I do come
from a family of like we give you a gift
and then we use it against you later yes
okay so exactly I want you to deal with
that put this in your back pocket the
things we did to keep ourselves safe and
alive when we were younger become the
things that destroy the relationships
our relationships as adults
so as a kid you knew that extra ice
cream is going to come with some garbage
attached to it you knew when dad called
and said you can borrow 100 bucks for
fill in the blank that was going to come
with some heavy heavy costs
and so you learn to shut that down you
learn to say no I'll do this by myself
I'm going to be a Lone Ranger through
the rest of my life and then your body
said we can't live like this that's
depression
and now practicing relationships moving
forward
is you unlearning the things that kept
you alive when you were a kid or now the
things that are hurting you so we're
going to practice letting George buy me
dinner
because I know George isn't gonna it you
know if George proves over time that he
is just using me or he expects something
in return cool I learned something about
my friendship with George I learned
something about George so I'm going to
quit rights I'm not going to over
moralize it I'm not going to beat myself
up I'm not going to feel shame over it I
learned something about George he didn't
tell me the truth cool I'm just not
going to take uh food from him next time
I'm not going to let him pay for my
concert ticket next time awesome sure
that makes sense yeah it makes a lot of
sense yeah and so I feel like I'm not
the only one that struggles with that
because you do everyone does yeah
everyone does we were George and I were
just talking about this off air
um that it's hard to
take something from somebody when we all
have that friend who's like um last year
I gave you 4.28 cents at Wendy's and you
owe me for
gosh you know what I mean it's the worst
impression of me I'm not saying that was
George but that's for sure George
um that's why I love venmo right we can
just settle it right now we can all move
on with our lives
um I think there's something about
practicing
those relational needs that we have as
young adults and into adulthood that are
completely opposite to what we needed to
do to survive when we were kids
okay and you deserve friends and
relationships and in fact if you're
healing from depression
a powerful strong loving community that
walks alongside you is the Cornerstone
of getting well okay yeah you're worth
that is that cool
yes thank you so much let him pay for
your dinner and stand on those other
nights that you just can't get out of
bed feel free to say no that's cool or
tell them they can grab tacos and show
up at your house that'd be fantastic all
right let's take one more let's go to
Chris in Oakland hey Chris we're right
up against the clock so get right to
your question
okay hey how you do how you guys doing
so I'll keep it quick for you guys so I
start my new job uh next Monday and I
have I read the numbers and I need a
payoff student I want to pay out my
student loan debt and I write my numbers
and it should be I should be debt free
in about 16 16 and a half months but I
do have a quick question so I have a
traditional IRA no
don't do it don't do it
don't don't do what don't cash it out
oh wow you knew what I was gonna say huh
don't do it man anytime someone says I
got a pile of debt and so I have this a
retirement account don't do it don't do
it
okay do not do it okay get a second job
get a third job work 20 hours a day and
I'm I'm a maniac about sleep as a
Cornerstone of physical and mental
health work really hard do whatever you
got to do do not cash that thing out
there's fees oh there's penalties and on
top of that you're robbing from your
future self and that is never worth it
so the future Chris will be pissed if
you have non-retirement you can cash
that kind of stuff out but if you've got
IRAs 401ks don't touch it use your
future income what it does tells me is
that your gazelle intents you want to do
whatever it takes to get out of this
debt and that might mean I'm going to
cut stuff in my budget cut expenses cut
subscriptions do some side hustles get a
raise get a second job and those things
are all great because they don't rob you
from your future
got you what's your what's your new job
Chris
oh I'm gonna be working as a lab
assistant at a Stanford Hospital oh
that's shabby Place huh man
we all have to we all have to just take
one for the team every once in a while
good grief okay lab assistant at
Stanford just making a monthly challenge
go all right I'm at 16 months of debt
payoff how can I shave that down to 15
or 14. and so I love the idea of making
a challenge of how much extra income can
I bring how much how little can I live
on during this time to make it make the
sacrifices painless as possible and
you're gonna get there man 16 months
ain't that bad
all right that sounds good thank you
guys so much for your help absolutely
excellent always think about future
Chris that's what that's what adults do
the theme of the day that's exactly
right
um George I remember
paying off Consumer Debt the temptation
to cut Corners is so great oh we love a
good shortcut it's the American wage oh
it's so great it's why we invented the
drive-through and fast food we don't
even have to get we don't have to kill a
cow ourselves that's right hey I want to
thank Jenna will AJ even Andrew and
especially Bobby back there thank you
George and thank you America for
listening to the Ramsey show we will be
back soon take care
[Music]
foreign
co-host of the Ramsey show did you know
over 18 million people listen to the
Ramsey ramzio every week a lot of those
people listen on one of our 600 plus
radio stations across the country to
find a station